pilot to Bombardier it's Monday pilot to
Bombardier it's Monday come in
you
pilot to Bombardier now that's how you
start a [ __ ] Monday you
understand me
you take them kale and carrot milkshake
with gentian shove it up your [ __ ]
mom's [ __ ] [ __ ] we start the day like
[ __ ] savages be understanding you can
either be a Gentile or you can live like
a doctor like myself with my little
[ __ ] robe on and [ __ ] and when I mean
doctor it's a state of mind you
understand me it's a state of [ __ ]
mind you could walk down the street like
a doctor or you could be a [ __ ]
Gentile but it don't matter and it's
Monday
the birds are just are just [ __ ] put
it's gonna be out one bout of your balls
get that [ __ ] [ __ ] top thin cuz
it's gonna sweat like a [ __ ]
right but you don't want I think I'm
gonna do with me you anything else heat
is heat you know I'm saying when you're
living out what the [ __ ] is he gonna do
to you and we all live in [ __ ] hell
so get up grab your [ __ ] nut sack get
that pipe wrench
cuz this life [ __ ] its life and
it goes by [ __ ] fast one day I was
walking around looking like the Elvis
look at me now I'm all [ __ ] up I got
holes in my face I can't see out of my
right eye because of the blow don't
blame about nothing else but whatever
the [ __ ] it is it's Monday [ __ ]
but that all aside I don't care if
you're good-looking fat [ __ ] ugly
whatever the [ __ ] you got to get out
there and tell these [ __ ] which
time and I'm saying find the Chinese guy
it's what the July we do Chinese people
even sell [ __ ] fireworks anymore
that's it no more Chinese beam usually
around this time to eat Chinese people
look at you a little weird and [ __ ] they
got some in the trunk not him
they just keep [ __ ] a little I don't
even know what I got a [ __ ] that
behavior not like that but anyway that's
got nothing to do with the situation at
hand [ __ ] it's Monday write
your goals pull the skin back on your
helmet wash it ladies toothbrush the
[ __ ] monkey cuz it's gonna be a good
[ __ ] week understand but enough with
the chitty-chat and Joey let's get this
party started after I opened up with
this [ __ ] we wouldn't know labor well
right off the bat I took a chance I
Columbus
boat number one it goes my [ __ ]
cleaning goddamn I gotta climb down
there now
now I'm taking you to deep murky waters
with the Baris oh geez this [ __ ] here
that's right caca like this that tricot
liquors going on deep into the murky
waters it's Monday if you don't know
what you don't make believe you know
what the [ __ ] you do pass down that's
what i'ma do fees I don't know I just
walk around I don't know no I'm a
[ __ ] wall and if I could pull off you
Coppola
I love this [ __ ] boy I already have my
[ __ ] humming no smoothie I took this
[ __ ] like a horse I had a flush eight
times and that's it I did a couple
push-ups I got the joint choked up roped
up I'm gonna wash my [ __ ] here in a
minute
and I said it's [ __ ] Monday I got
jujitsu I gotta talk to some man about a
[ __ ] dog yeah I got a podcast at 6
o'clock tonight
you don't meet dog I'm a man of many
[ __ ] [ __ ] and I hope you are too
you know you got yourself some coke you
gotta [ __ ] sell [ __ ] stolen
watches and you gotta have a day job
that's the economy today if you're not
doing that you're slipping time second
or your head Luna gonna box around while
I'm wet too
whoo now really tell you know you take
care of our setting yeah moon do it to
yours I'm but go seize it didn't get
butter not beat up boy today you gotta
put your [ __ ] batteries on that's it
don't get me started
there's a big [ __ ] American week and
I'm saying somewhere along the line
you're gonna hear an anthem or [ __ ]
Pro [ __ ] American speech get ready for
local Joey positions gotta [ __ ] end
look at that hit knocked my [ __ ] long
I like the field rubbing against my
[ __ ] fibula whatever the [ __ ] that is
a bit anyway I said the [ __ ] I'm
stumped
I gotta live the actors idiot I am The
King of Swing what a [ __ ] stomach
that's the most important thing on a
Monday is the truth you know what's
going on they know what's going on so
there's no misunderstandings so when you
show up with a [ __ ] baton and a
[ __ ] helmet start whacking them over
there that are sitting there but what
did i do what did i do we were just
talking what the [ __ ] we were just
talking get it together godson
look at that huh but I do some police's
breathing exercises I do miss dr.
police's breathing exercises proof up
its smoking understand that's how we
[ __ ] do it here anyway so I am
starting to sweat if it we have a sweat
from smokin reefer
that's when you know there's a problem
about three minutes away from having
ambulances who is ambulances from reefer
at eight o'clock on a Monday morning
uncle Joey does you know why because he
loves you that's what he loves you ain't
[ __ ] around which I love you
[ __ ] they can't be on here my
daughter's inside watching bubble gum
paste again it's a beautiful day to be
alive her dad's have here smoking dope
like a [ __ ] degenerate with four
thousand other [ __ ] mother luckily
ace will kiss her [ __ ] we got the world
by the balls they're serving up [ __ ] by
the platter and you're sitting in your
house put your [ __ ] video games get it
together
I got my plan being a pen cap what do
you do your pipe gets [ __ ] dirty
gotta clean it out some way and I'm
saying should we do one just burnt my
finger should we do one more what are
you ready to [ __ ] throw some heat are
you ready to rock uncle Joey
then [ __ ] it let's do one more listen I
don't have to put weed in this pipe I
just light it man you [ __ ] get stung
that's how much did this living p8c in
this [ __ ] I like that he was
going out
hell no my can't-miss no my canvas don't
make chemists mean don't burn the
[ __ ] call me and interrupt me doing a
periscope of my favorite [ __ ] people
let's go back to this [ __ ] death camp
right right a wrong right or wrong well
you got a [ __ ] jumping on a monday
we're not gonna jump in with both
[ __ ] hands
[Applause]
oh yeah let's fill this up let's do one
more because you know that's what we do
here ain't gonna show up here I'm
getting so high the taste
oh [ __ ] it so this tastes like ass I'm
gonna [ __ ]
and that's it the smoke signals have
been sent
do you understand me people know what
time it is over here on the Dia's corner
there really smell all over the
neighborhood they're walking their dogs
what is that smell uncle Joey's up set
the [ __ ] world on fire [ __ ]
I got a gas can and a book of matches
young saying and it's windy so that's
the way you gotta [ __ ] make it like
you got a gas can you're gonna do some
Jewish lightning but it's windy out and
you gotta manage that's [ __ ] life
right there you haven't figured it out
go [ __ ] yourself
and that's it that's that I'll see you
[ __ ] tonight 6 o'clock sharp
get ready bring your pipes is an
interesting one tonight
I Love You God suckers don't let nobody
[ __ ] with you keep your eyes on the
prize and get off the [ __ ] phone
there's no reason to look at that
[ __ ] phone all day just a bunch of
Mook sending your dumb [ __ ] uncle Joey
loves you stay black 6 o'clock tonight
[ __ ]